[Music]
welcome back to a new episode of what's
up prof hello walter hi martin we're
back again how are you doing yes we're
back
so we continue a little bit on
what we've done in the previous uh
what's up episodes now many of our
programs
develop as a consequence of
circumstances
it seems
as if there is a need
and somehow
one needs to address it because the
issues are quite serious
yes it's we cannot ignore
what hap what's happening and the
questions that gets getting asked
so
let's delve into this and ask the lord's
blessing again we certainly will need it
our father in heaven thank you very much
for this opportunity to discuss
important matters
we ask that you enlighten us our minds
with the holy spirit and that you bless
this discussion please in jesus name
amen
now martin our title today
is somewhat
provocative
but it has a kink in the tail as well
to
try and make it less provocative
the title is how to survive the
babylonians in laodicea
now there are two aspects to this title
there is a babylonian
trend or thinking pattern that needs to
be addressed
and we state in loud it's here
and that touches us all
exactly it's not putting anybody above
anybody else correct so
laodicea is the state
in which the church is
and it is a message to each and every
single one of us
lest we become puffed up and think that
we are more important or
whatever
stature we want to assign to to us or
anyone else
uh laodicea brings us back to
earth yeah and it's also a state that
you don't want to continue being in no
you don't want to be in that lukewarm
state lukewarm is actually
a major problem
and the lord defines it and he says you
know it's better to be
cold
or hot but this lukewarm state is the
worst of them all
and then we think you know all right
we've made it we are now
part of
those that understand whatever the plan
of salvation is trying to tell us where
we are in the stream of time
and uh
that does not make us the bee's knees
that means we have been admitted to
intensive care
that's a very good comparison yes so
we're all in intensive care
and some of us come with baggage and
some of us
pick up baggage along the way
and some of us
when we are
schooled in the world
we pick up the ways of the world it took
moses 40 years to get rid of the ways of
the world before he was fitted and
squared to become the leader of god's
people 40 years
in the wilderness looking at sheep
totally
different from what he was doing the
first 40 years yes so let's not be too
hard
on anyone
and
when we talk about babylonians
in
laodicea
martin there's an issue which is
often neglected in in the word of god
and most denominations
don't even touch on it
and that's the question of present truth
in second peter chapter 1 verse 12 we
read wherefore i will not be negligent
to put you always in remembrance of
these things though you know them
and be established in present truth
that's a very good statement it's a
magnificent statement and it comes from
the vociferous peter
so there are two things that need to be
addressed in this verse
the remembrance
of things
so nothing in the scripture is
unimportant
and we need to know it all
we need to be reminded
all the time
what
it says and how god communicates with us
but then there is a
special aspect which is especially
important for a particular time
and that is called present truth
and i like the
wording before that you have to be
established yes in the present time and
you mustn't be negligent yeah
if these things happen and how many
times must you be remembered or reminded
always
it's it's uh you know if you look at
this verse and you you mull of it
there's a lot of depth in it
so in the time that this was written
what was the present
well at this stage jesus the jesus as
the messiah was the present truth that
was the present truth
and
did the people embrace it and rejoice
the judge definitely not but there was a
triumphant entry
so there were people that were singing
and rejoicing
and it was just a matter of days
and the circumstances changed entirely
yeah okay so they probably misunderstood
the present truth yes and they weren't
established in it and they had a wrong
concept of the present truth they
thought that now the romans would be
driven up everything would go
honky-dory as far as they were concerned
they were going to be on top of the pile
and uh
exactly the opposite happened yeah if
you pull that through to today
i think we've got a lot of people that's
also
misinterpreting present truth yes so
present truth
needs to be based on scripture
and
present truth never negates
any portion of scripture
right
so present truth is very very important
and present truth needs to be preached
and we need to be established as a
people in present truth
if the disciples
had not been established in present
truth
would the gospel have made any inroads
in the world no
and they weren't established in prison
truth before their conversion exactly
and their conversion came after
the crucifixion
so they didn't understand either so how
do you become established in present
truth you must
be reminded of the stream of events and
you must have a special truth for this
time
know if you go to the book of isaiah we
read here in isaiah 48 from verse 2
for they call themselves the holy city
and stay themselves upon the god of
israel the lord of hosts is his name
he's talking to his people and they
think you know we are the holy city we
are the chosen people of god
we
are the ones that are in favor with god
we are lauretia if we put it into
present
form right
so they had this puffed up notion
that they were the bee's knees
and then he says to them i've declared
the former things from the beginning and
they went forth out of my mouth and i
showed them
i did them suddenly and they came to
pass
so the lord says i put the prophetic
word
into my word so that you would know that
i am god because all prophecy is being
fulfilled
according to my word
and in spite of it why did i do that why
do i make so sure that you can see that
i really am who i say
because i knew that thou art obstinate
and thy neckers and iron sinew and thy
brow
brass
stubborn people
i've even from the beginning declared it
to thee before it came to pass i showed
that the lest thou should say mine idol
has done them and my engraven image and
my molten image has commanded them
now the elevation of self is also an
idol
yeah
especially
so if you think well
why should i say thank you i planted
this food
yeah i bought it with my money at the
supermarket why should i say thank you
well i think cain had the same attitude
attitude
who made it grow
who designed the seed
exactly we gave life to that seed all
right so they were a stubborn and
obstinate people and they served as a
type
now how stubborn were there by the time
that jesus came onto the scene
well here's the speech of stephen
acts 7 51 you stiff-necked and
uncircumcised in heart and ears you do
always resist the holy ghost
as your father's dead so do ye
what and who's he talking to
to the leaders in the church he's
talking to the leaders of the church the
representatives even of the sanhedrin
which of the prophets have not your
fathers persecuted
and they have slain them which showed
before of the coming of the just one of
whom ye have now been the betrayers and
the murderers
who have received the law by the
disposition of angels and have not kept
it
the condition at the time of jesus
and this was the time when they were
reminded
that the present truth was that the
messiah
was to come into the world
had god made special provision to remind
them of that no yes
didn't he send the wise men didn't they
knock at the doors in jerusalem and say
hello where where's the prince where's
the king
and didn't herod get all excited and
make them study the scriptures exactly
so they were supposed to have known but
they had to go back to study the
scriptures
so they were stiff-necked and
uncircumstanced in heart and ears and
they wouldn't listen they wouldn't
listen
they didn't accept present truth
they rejected present truth
they thought they were established
but they rejected the present truth
could the same happen to us yes you see
i think also
the problem is
they even knew prophecy but they didn't
put it to present truth they didn't
couple that together it's so important
that we realize that present truth does
not negate old truth
did the fact that jesus had come into
the world and was the messiah of the
world negate any of the prophecies of
the old testament no
it fulfilled them fulfilled and
established it to the letter
did they accept it
no
are we in danger of doing perhaps the
same thing i think so
so in other words can we say martin that
old truths are still truth
but all truths are not necessarily
present truth although they might be
encapsulated in the old truth
so what is special about present truth
it's a special
event a special message
for the time in which we are living
okay
so
let's ask ourselves what was present
truth for moses
getting out of egypt the promise that
was being kept by god that they have he
will save them out of egypt yes that
this people that god had
promised that he would give them an
inheritance
now was the time for this event to take
place
now
interesting
moses before he became the leader of the
israelites while he was still a prince
in egypt
did he realize
that he
or let's say did he have a feeling that
he had a calling to be the deliverer yes
but he misinterpreted what that should
be yes he thought it was going to be a
military campaign right he was going to
do it and he had all the training and he
had all the expertise
and he had been educated at the highest
institutes of learning of the egyptians
and when he saw those people fighting
and arguing and treating the israelites
poorly he whacked the one and buried him
in the sand right
and
he had an idea
that the time must be near
but
40 years off you go pal
into the wilderness
to learn
and to unlearn
so that's very interesting so there was
a present truth and he understood it
but he misapplied it yeah
he understood there is a present truth
but
he didn't understand what it is okay
what about jeremiah did he understand
that there was a present truth
yes
but he was also
dishearted he was very disheartened
and the present truth at that time was
the babylonians are coming to destroy
this place
and we are the people of god this will
never happen was the attitude of the
others
and so when he kept on saying it what
did they do to him
they wanted to cue him
yes and they treated him
very nicely right
no
and eventually he became so disheartened
but he was a fiery character i i can
identify with jeremiah i want to sit on
a rock one day and talk to jeremiah for
a long time
because you know they tore up his dvds
and throw threw them in the fire and he
said well let's make another couple of
dvds and add some more details
and really irritate them
and it did right yeah that was for sure
it's interesting
so there are some parallels and then
there's an etc of course there were
other prophets living at exactly the
same time daniel was living
in babylon ezekiel was prophesying those
are
the major prophets and
they were preaching present truth
was present truth popular
no
unfortunately not at all not not for the
people of god and not even for the
people
outside of israel exactly all right so
we've established one thing now present
truth has never been popular
never
present truth was not accepted by the
majority
present truth was even to a large extent
rejected by those that should be
preaching it yeah
can we say that
so this is a pattern
can we expect a repeat of the pattern
there's nothing new under the sun
there's nothing new under the sun martin
i think we're already
getting into hot water here
all right so
that brings us to
this very important question
what is present truth for our time
the soon return or the imminent return
of jesus yes
and the three angels messages right
that's present truth for our time it's a
very popular message time of the
judgment has come
worship him were made the heavens the
earth the sea the springs of water
babylon is fallen is fallen
and a little bit louder she's become a
house of demon and a house of every
unclean and detestable bird
come out of her my people that you
receive not of her plagues
do not accept the mark of the beast
because if you accept the mark of the
beast the following will happen
very popular message right
that's as popular as jeremiah's verse
all right now what happens if you're
living in the midst of the babylonians
and you tell them you've fallen you've
become a house of demons
the babylonians will rejoice right
no definitely not the babylonians won't
like that message
and some
are
not inclined to give that message
particularly if they have
very close relations with the
babylonians
so the present truth in our time is no
more popular than present truth was in
there's a vault
you agree yep
okay
so that brings us to the next question
why are some leaders so hesitant to
expose babylon
and the mark of the beast
well i think you answered that
in your previous sentence
they are probably a little bit too much
affiliated with the babylonians or
there's another possibility not
necessary
affiliation
but what about inebriation okay i have
to explain
inebriation is when you have
imbibed in a spot of beverage that goes
to your head you've become drunk with
the wine of babylon
is it possible to become inebriated with
the wine of babylon yes
easily
because it's such a sweet tasting wine
all right
now if you want to be popular in the
world
then what message
would you cling to present truth or
compromise with babylonian
theology well if we want to stand we
have to embrace present truth and
go against the bible okay so could you
expect uh conflict within the church yes
are there people that think it is a good
idea to get the education from
babylonian institutes
are some institutes more babylonian than
others
yes
i think so right so you have a you have
a sort of a small ghost board you have a
choice
you can go to an ultra babylonian
institute and receive your education
sometimes unknowingly and sometimes by
choice
and you can go to a halfway one and you
can go to one that preaches everything
including present truth you have a
choice right
now
is there a
a tendency
if you go through the history of israel
for babylon
to make inroads even amongst god's
people
continually
i don't think there was a time when
babylonian inroads was not
in israel
okay
so
they were very inclined towards baal
worship
and sometimes they got so bad
that they even started sacrificing their
children to these deities right
so martin if you look at the
solomon what was his problem
a woman
all right
women was his problem he had an
extraordinary affinity for women right
now women in a theological sense what
are they referred to
churches churches so do you think we
might have modern day
solomons with an extraordinary affinity
for women
yes
eh
and he loved them
and he interacted with them and he did
all things to please them and he did did
he bring moloch into the temple did he
set up images
did he
build altars did so he really appeased
them right do you think we might have
similar things come into god's church
well we started off speaking about
luditsia
and that's one of the attributes of that
church
and it's lukewarm
so
that means you know
if things don't always go right
there's not necessarily a trumpet
that says uh there's something seriously
wrong here ex
rather keep quiet to keep the peace now
if you go back to ancient israel did it
sometimes become so bad
that it became so blatantly apostate
that
it was absolutely necessary for god to
intervene definitely
quite a few times quite a few times
right and so we have this roller coaster
throughout history
and we must expect a similar roller
coaster within the church
now why are we talking about
this issue why are we even
mentioning
this issue
well
because martin
we have received
many
written letters we have received many
phone calls
and some people are at the point of
despair
and i received a phone call just this
morning
on the issue and a
mail on this issue where people are
saying
we cannot handle the apostasy anymore in
the church it is so hard for us that it
seems to us as if this church has become
babylon
and we
cannot imagine hanging in there
and further associating ourselves with
it
and then they would ask me the question
how do you manage to hang in there with
everything that has happened
to you personally
and
to others as well
why why are you hanging in are you
either you're insane
are you blind you can't see what's
happening
or there must be some other recipe
can you help us
so martin that is why we had a little
chat and said oh how do we deal with
this let's see what we can do about it
and the other question that always pops
up
is why does god permit this
right
why doesn't he stop it if this is god's
people why did he
not intervene a long time ago
question did he intervene to prevent the
crucifixion of jesus
no
it had to be done
did he intervene to prevent the
murder
and the martyrdom of the disciples
no
did he intervene when they
threw john into boiling oil and then
banished him to patmos when that didn't
work out no
no
so let's look at that aspect
this is the aspect of the long suffering
and patience of god in the face of a
stubborn and obstinate people
we read in exodus 5 22
and moses returned unto the lord and
said lord
wherefore hast thou so evil entreated
this people
why is it that thou has sent me for
since i came to pharaoh to speak in thy
name he has done evil to this people
neither has thou delivered thy people at
all
do you think he's slightly peeved
i love these stories yeah it brings
you can resonate with it yes absolutely
especially in the time we are living and
you can resonate
why you're not doing anything what's
going on here
and
god answers him eventually in exodus 6 1
and says
then the lord said unto moses now
shalt thou see what i will do to pharaoh
for with a strong hand shall he let them
go and with a strong hand shall he drive
them out of his land
so there comes a point when god says
enough right
uh sometimes it feels very long before
that happens it is
and he didn't tell moses
go on your own there you go
no he had to stay with the people he had
to stay with the people they had to go
through this whole turmoil eventually
they came out and it didn't take them
many hours before they started grumbling
and they had to learn
how god works in the providence of god
and it took 40 years of wandering in the
wilderness before their perfect
offspring went into
canaan right
yeah
again the answer is no
no
nothing perfect
nothing
so
we will have this problem with us for a
long time
just think about poor old jeremiah
he says righteous art thou o lord
when i plead with thee yet let me talk
with thee of thy judgments wherefore
does the way of the wicked prosper
wherefore are all they happy
that deal very treacherously
it's a good question right
i don't understand lord
i've had enough of this nonsense
all of these people are prospering like
green trees and uh look at me i'm
i'm miserable and i'm poorly treated etc
eventually he says in chapter 20 verse 8
for since i spoke i cried out
i cried violence and spoiled because the
word of the lord was made a reproach
unto me in a derision
daily
then i said i will not make mention of
him nor speak any more in his name
ah but his word was in mine heart as a
burning fire shut up in my bones and i
was weary of forbearing and i could not
stay
he couldn't keep it in
he had to speak
and the more he spoke the more in
trouble he got
right it sounds familiar it just sounds
so familiar
every time you open your mouth
you get a ton of bricks on you
and
this is the way it is but
who told him to speak
god told him to so that's the main thing
you mustn't you must
burn through because god is
leading all right so god told him to
speak
but he also says that that word
was a fire in his heart
it was shut up in his bones he had
internalized
present truth exactly yes established it
he had established himself in present
truth and he was preaching present truth
and he was greeted with a ton of bricks
what can we expect
nothing less all right so is the modern
sunny dread sanhedrin going to come down
on you like a ton of bricks can you
expect anything else yep
all right but now let's not be unkind
are there nicodemus's in the modern
sanhedrin
there will always be all right
let's ask another question are there
potential pauls
definitely in the modern sanhedrin
definitely yes
okay
so even though matters might look
very dark
there might be light at the end of the
tunnel because you never know maybe that
guy who's spitting fire at you and
having you arrested and thrown in jail
and beaten to a pulp
might become the next evangelist
what happens then right
you always have to let god do the work
okay so let's not
judge anything before the time
let's not take paul apart
and let's not misinterpret nicodemus
that's the thing
we can condemn the action but not the
person ah
that is the point and even if we see
the most
liberal actions
remember aaron
right
remember aaron and his actions
so if we look at the leaders in the
church
and we make a comparison john 3 verse 9
nicodemus comes to jesus and nicodemus
answered and said unto him how can these
things be
now jesus told him that he has to be
reborn he has to get a new heart he was
the leader he was in the sanhedrin he
was in the gc
that's where he was right
and here he comes and jesus tells him
sorry
but you've missed the boat
and he says how can this be and jesus
answered and said unto him at our master
or a teacher of a leader or a
one of those
of israel
and knows not these things
can it happen
oh for sure
okay
and it takes a man to acknowledge that
you don't know all right
now did he immediately pack up
everything and follow jesus no
no
but the interesting thing is he mulded
over and he watched and he studied
and when those rocks were ramped and
that earthquake came and that
sky was darkened and the sun didn't
bring its light
his faith was forever established
whereas the faith of the disciples was
totally destroyed yeah
isn't that interesting very
a good warning
yes for present truth for us and those
disciples had the privilege of sitting
at jesus's feet
eating his words on a daily basis and
nicodemus's faith was established and
theirs was destroyed by the very same
events
so let's not be too harsh
but let's be pretty straight
william tyndall
i like that man
god's rebel
that's what they called him ryan
and uh he said to the papal legate
if god spared my life in many years i
will cause a boy who drives a plow to
know more of the scriptures than you do
he was talking to the religious leaders
right
so he's talking
through this individual to the whole
papal hierarchy and all the learned men
of the time
martin let's be very bold now and ask
do you think there might be
people
that have studied the scripture
that tyndale provided
and have internalized it and might
know more
about the plan of salvation and the
working of the holy spirit and the
meaning and the depth of the conversion
that takes place than many a theologian
in our church yes plowboys plowboys you
think there might be plow boys that know
more than the professors at some of our
institutes i'm sure
i'm absolutely convinced that it is the
case
now
what if
the theologian should get the same
attitude as the plow boy
that's what happened to paul yes then he
will be of worth you will have such
power it will be unbelievable
again you have to believe like a child
so it brings you back into that harmony
all right so we have all of these
dynamics happening in the church
psalms 37 35 says i've seen the wicked
in great power
and spreading himself like a green bay
tree
yet he passed away and lo he was not
yea i sought him
but he could not be found
in other words
we're looking at the wickedness we're
looking at the apostasy we're looking at
all of these things and we think
how long sovereign lord how long will
you permit these things in the church
and like moses say you've done nothing
about this
and he's talking to god
and then
there were no more yeah there came a
time pharaoh
it was god time when god says now you
will see what i will do okay
now i think we've
laid a little bit of groundwork for our
discussion
and perhaps it's time for a little bit
of
personal reflection
we've had many experiences in this
church right
i've been in this uh situation somewhat
longer than you
and you've had quite a number of very
profound interesting experiences right
in the very short time that i've been in
the church yes yes how long have you
been in the church now martin since
2015.
2015. seven is a good number yeah
it's a very good number
mine changes every year
but it's somewhere between 35 and 37 i
can't remember anyway i can i guess i
can work it out it's about 35 years at
least
and
when i think of my experiences
that was the question how do you handle
it
how how can you handle it
uh how many times have i been
before the sanhedrin
numerous times right
well you were
in the last two years
two twice
in the last two years twice yes the lord
is very good to me prior to that a
number of times
before
the sanhedrin
i've been
called onto carpets
and i have been addressed
in ways which
i would not consider exactly
brotherly kindness
so yeah i've had these experiences and
uh there were times when you think like
jeremiah i'm not going to speak in this
name anymore
and then ah but the word was the fire in
my heart and i could not
and i think back on the times
when these things happened
and uh when you come into contact with
blatant apostasy
now uh i had the privilege of being on
some
committees and i've told many of these
stories but let's just deal with a dis
different aspect
there in my stories i told what happened
but i didn't talk about the
personalities
now we don't want to mention
any names
but we want to show that in every
echelon
there are people
that sound like babylonians
and there are people in every echelon
that act like babylonians
and maybe there are people in every
echelon that are babylonians
and you have to deal with it right yes
now
when i was called to
faith and science meetings
i met that whole plethora
and i was also very closely associated
with the entire hierarchy and leadership
of the church
and i find some of it very troubling
and some of it very
not only troubling but extremely
disturbing
so you're sitting there in one of these
meetings
and someone is giving a speech which is
so
blatantly apostate
that you cannot believe that that can
come out of the mouth of a believer
believes nothing about prison truth but
nothing
doesn't believe in a literal creation
doesn't believe that jesus performed
miracles doesn't believe that anything
happened that is of a supernatural
nature in the bible everything is
naturalistic believes this world is
millions and millions of years old and
that anybody who doesn't go along with
that line of thinking is a
and you're sitting next to leaders
and i'm sitting
amongst one of
the biblical research institute people
sitting next to me
and i'm listening to this talk
and
i'm still relatively new to all of this
and i am stunned
i'm absolutely stunned i can't believe
what i am hearing this cannot be true
not in this church
and eventually this individual there in
the front starts sprouting
pantheistic ideas but so blatant
and these are higher people i mean these
are deans in our theological institutes
and in our medical institutes and
they're talking this kind of talk this
is pure babylonian
this is what you would expect at the
worst level
in a secular university
that has
the professors all in the realms of
atheism
and this is coming
so i tap
this member of the biblical research
institute
and i say to him
but but that's that's
pantheism he looks at me he says no it's
not pantheism it's pananthism
and he keeps chatting with his friend
not faced at all
so i think to myself this is very
strange he's not faced
i'm so agitated i can explode
he's perfectly calm
and he's not even
listening properly he's chatting away
but whatever it doesn't bother him at
all
now
my feeling is what's this man doing in
our ranks he's a babylonian he should go
he has no right to call himself a
seventh-day adventist talking like this
but there's no action taken against him
there's no action whatsoever there's no
consequences to what he's preaching
now would that surprise you martin
yes
of course because you when you come into
the church and you've just learned all
these truths this does not
fit how does this person is preaching in
the front they
fit into a leadership position within
this church
and why are the members even of the
biblical research institute
not faced
and i haven't read any articles against
these people or anything of that nature
but preach present truth
and they will pick up their pens
and they will lambaste you from one side
of the planet to the other unfortunately
do you see that's the truth it because
it's happened
it happens it's my experience your
experience my experience especially
across the past two years yes
and then they put me into this into a
subcommittee
with another gentleman
who also
didn't believe in a six-day creation
didn't believe in miracles
and
this was someone who had a very high
position at one of our universities
in fact at one stage he had the highest
position at that university that you
can't possibly have within a university
and i sat in a subcommittee with this
man
and i looked him through and thought to
myself
what is this individual doing in the
church
what's he doing there
he's sprouting all of this nonsense that
is not part of the bible or the spirit
of prophecy
and uh i was still a young fiery
individual at that stage now i'm an old
fiery individual
and i thought you know i will try and
see if i can get a reaction from him
so i
i said some things like
you know anybody who believes what he
believes
must be an idiot
especially if he belongs to this church
he should be he should be out there in
the world what's he doing in this church
such a person doesn't belong here it
must be you know either
it must be out there that he can be
evangelized again yes
it shouldn't be in the church and i
started saying some things of that
nature
do you think he was phased
yeah no cool and calm he didn't care at
all he was cool calm and collected
it was
perinde a cadaver
like a corpse like a corpse
totally impermeable to anything that i
said
and i looked at his eyes and they were
ice cold and i thought you know
i would expect a jesuit to look like
this
and i thought to myself i wonder whether
this person is a jesuit what is this
babylonian doing in the church
and why is the church not doing anything
against this individual
that's how i felt
and i thought i was alone
and i was totally devastated
and then
i mean there were a couple of hundred
people there and a hundred
scientists
and
then one day i got a tap on the shoulder
and a meek and mild little gentleman
that nobody would
probably notice
within those ranks tapped me on the
shoulder and said
would you like to attend a little
private meeting
and i said
okay what's it about he said no
i just want to chat a little bit
but you come to room so and so
at such and such a time so i went
and there's that about
i don't know how many i can't remember
15 20 people
and
they were all scientists
people within the church
and i looked them through i didn't know
any of them i didn't know who they were
or whatever
and i just walked into this atmosphere
which was the exact opposite of what i
had experienced before
these people were so concerned
about what was happening
that they were literally
weeping
literally
and i thought to myself well what's
going on
here and then they said you know
we're on a terrible state
we have a terrible situation on our
hands
we need to pray for this church and we
need to pray for these people
and they went on their knees and they
prayed
and you walk out of there martin
and what do you think you feel
empathy
all right
and you realize it's not all bad
now were these people that were in that
room that were also
prominent people in their fields
where they're the most vocal in those
meetings no no
i didn't even know them right
now at one stage i was
working
with some of the people high up in
[Music]
general conference organizations like
geoscience
and there i met people
that i went out into the field with and
that we discussed issues with and i
spent six weeks with them
six weeks
and there were two in particular that i
remember
and they were elderly
now
you know modern if i had to look at them
today and say uh
were there a house on fire
i would say no
they were quiet people
were they great orators
could they you know captivate an
audience with their with their talk
no
they were anything but
they were just so down to earth
and i went into the field with
them on different occasions
and the one would speak and he'd speak
so so dryly
and he would say oh
they would explain something and he
would carry on like this but you know
what
after a while you realize what these
people were about
they were so full of faith
they were such
godly people that they put me to shame
and i still remember the one was quite
elderly
and
we walked up a mountain a very high
mountain
and
he was walking and he was walking
slowly
and i thought to myself i put a little
bit of fire under you
just get on with it what's the matter
with all of these people why they like
this
but you know what he never ever stopped
and everybody else was young and was
going up that mountain and then he'd get
way behind or whatever and
then they were puffing and huffing and
he would go by at the same pace and
carry on and
he was
he was amazing
but he had such deep faith
and these people made such an impression
on me and these were the leaders of that
institute today i don't know what that
institute looks like i haven't had any
dealings with the current people but
they made a tremendous
impression upon me
and they were not invited
to any of those meetings well because
they said that they were retired
but the apostate ones that were retired
they were there
and it seemed so biased to me
someone i've met babylonians in this
church
and i've seen the acceptance of the
babylonians in this church
and it freaked me out
and then i met the others
and so we could go through
the names and through the lists of all
of these people
when i started preaching present truth
then things got a little bit
uncomfortable
because there are those that are in very
close connection with babylonian
institutes we spoke about echomanism and
all of those issues
and it was very uncomfortable for some
if i would say
who babylon was
the fallen protestant churches
the
papacy mention it by name and the dragon
religions everything to do with
spiritism
that's babylon
and if you then specify
present truth
the mark of the beast why babylon has
fallen that becomes very uncomfortable
and then especially if you say that they
belong to secret societies many of these
people
then the wheels come off
and they will tell you to stop speaking
about these things
and that's exactly what happened to
jeremiah
present truth wasn't popular right
troubler of israel you're a troubler of
israel and especially when i started
speaking about bible translations
and then you were banned and then you
were unbanned and then you were in
on the carpet
and i dealt with
the top echelon i mean division
presidents right a number of them
now most of them that i dealt with when
it came to these conflict issues
they were obviously calling me on the
carpet to reprimand me
so do you think they were you know very
brotherly inclined towards me
definitely not definitely not right
and
i sat in some of those meetings
and the way in which they talked
and the way in which they
addressed the issues
and the accusations that they made
and the distortions that they threw at
me and the blatant lies that they tried
to pin on me and the way in which they
tried to do that
i would not expect such treatment from
the worst of the secular universities in
the world let alone god's people
so this thoroughly shocked me that
god's leaders could be
of such a nature
and many of them were responsible for
bringing blatant babylonian teachings
and apostasy into the church
and the members of the church were
appalled at what some of these people
were doing
and then you want to write off that
entire leadership
that's where you get to
and then after the meeting you sit in an
office
and somebody comes in and starts talking
to you
and they're high up
in that very organization
and you realize they think exactly like
you do yeah the opposite of the other
the opposite of their attitude within
the same leadership organization
and the rest of the people the staff
they're also not on that bandwagon
they are also normal people
that have the same aspirations as you
have
and some of them you know
came into the truth because of
some of my lectures for example
so
there you meet these people and you
think to yourself no
this is
this is a disconcordance in my brain i
can't handle this
and you realize that there are people
in the highest echelons that are
weeping
and crying for what is happening
now one of the issues we spoke about
last time was the bible translations
right
so i was banned i was called into
meetings by the higher echelons
and the biblical research institute
they came down on me like a ton of
bricks
so i have considerable correspondence
with them
and
you would think now you know
why do these why do they think so
differently
and i would write them
letters and i would show them
you know martin
that there are so many people
that are involved in this bible
translation issue
you know how many books have been
written on the issue yeah hundreds it's
unbelievable
and many of those books come out of
adventist ranks
right and they're very powerful books
you've seen some of them you've read
some of them
now if you take the the rest of the
protestant world
there are protestants that feel so
strongly about this issue and they've
written so many books i mean i've got a
whole shelf full of them
and
read them and internalized them and
their arguments are so
profound it's unchallengeable you cannot
challenge that argument in my opinion at
least it's virtually impossible to
challenge those arguments and you know
what it comes right from the beginning
even in the time when the king james
was written and the times thereafter
when west cottonwood came out with their
writings
uh dean bergen for example i mean the
things that he wrote
in support of the received text and the
king james version were absolutely
profound
but the modern theological seminaries
and of course the catholic church and
its
universities they want to sweep that
under the rug
and i would write and i would give all
of these statements they would ignore it
flat it's like they don't exist
and i would and i think why are they so
impervious
to looking at
evidence for the alternative view why do
they run with the mainstream babylonian
thinking when there is all this evidence
and in one occasion
i gave a lot of
evidence from certain manuscripts what
they said etc etc
and i got this evidence
from the theological committee
of the
bible
now the
is a german bible
that was
put together based on the received text
because these people believed that the
received text is the original text and
should be given prominence again
now that committee consists of
top theologians
and i would give the evidence of these
top theologians and and if they would
just brush it aside didn't exist they
wouldn't even answer the questions
so eventually i got to the point and i
said what's the point of talking with
you you don't even answer my questions
do you still believe
like i said last time do you still
believe
that the pope is the antichrist and that
we have an enemy in the world do you
still believe present truth
and do you believe that the spirit of
prophecy is binding or not
and i received an answer
we don't have to answer those questions
you don't have to answer those questions
or you
averse to answering them because maybe
you're sitting in economical councils
and they're uncomfortable questions
and so i write back and says well then
neither do i have to answer your
questions anymore so our discussion is
over now you would think that you could
put that whole group into a category
you can't
because i was sitting at one of these
meetings
and a member came to me
privately
and we had a discussion for a number of
hours
and i realized
you know what
at every level
there are people that believe and stand
for righteousness some of them are just
more timid to speak openly that's it
and also sometimes
i know you've mentioned
at first somebody is
against and wants to fight it yes but
after some in good study on the subject
they come around and they say yes
there was one conference president in in
germany
it's not mentioned names
he was
he's one of the most gentle people that
i've ever met in my life the kindest
sweetest man
and
you know i had a
great affinity to him
he was really a gentle person
but when i started speaking about bible
translations he said to me you know what
i i haven't been trained like that and i
think now you really lost the plot
so i cannot support you any longer
but a couple of months later he wrote to
me and he says you know i studied this
thing through now
and i've come to the conclusion
that there really is a big problem here
and
so do you write everybody off just
because they don't see it at that moment
or don't want to accept it or you know
if somebody could show me
on paper
and show me from the spirit of prophecy
that i'm wrong
i would recant immediately
but unfortunately the bible and the
spirit of
prophecy are
not on the wavelength of the modern
theological world the more you study it
the more you get grounded
in that truth yes the more you study it
the more you get grounded so this is an
issue so at every single level
whether it be
the leadership in the church i mean
if you think about the leadership in
germany that banned me
and believe they have a legitimate
reason
which they don't because what they're
doing is totally unbiblical
but
be that as it may does that mean all the
leaders
are like that
i gave a i gave a lecture series in
germany
outside the church because i'm banned
within the church
and there were leaders that had the
courage to come onto the stage
and show solidarity
so you cannot
you cannot
paint everyone within this church with
the same brush
god has his people
there are nicodemus's in the sanhedrin
but we cannot deny that there are
babylonian inroads in the church
now this event where this german
representative
and vice chairman of an economical
committee
bowed down within this roman catholic
church in fact the very one
that was responsible for my
banning in a sense
that caused quite a stir
and people are asking do we stay in the
church considering that this is
happening in the church
so my answer is
i've met them
i've met both sides of them within
leadership
i've met both sides of them within the
scientific community
medical community i've met both sides of
them within the
normal church membership community it's
at every level martin that's it
so what will save this church
god will save this church and we need a
shaking right yes we need a shaking
now when people come to me and they say
and they're from the division
and they say to me you may not preach
that the pope is the
antichrist if people come and they write
articles public articles condemning what
i say and saying that the papacy has
changed it is no longer what it was in
the middle ages when the spirit of
prophecy says rome never changes
then do i leave the church because there
is a person that writes that even if he
is a union president
no
have you had experiences like this in
your
short tenure in the church oh definitely
i've
brought up
concerns
and
we're thinking especially about
spiritual formation
and
books that were training material
that had secular not even adventist
professors as authors from secular
universities and that's training
material and blatantly
spiritual formation in that books as
training material and i brought these
things up
with training directors
and
you were well received they said well we
never saw this we're going to get rid of
it immediately right yeah well did they
do that unfortunately it's still on
okay so that didn't happen so do we have
babylonian thinking in the church
definitely my wife and i were involved
with the evangelistic
organization and we had to go from
different churches all over provinces
and so on and there we quite
literally learned what you've explained
that there's different types of people
both sides in each
church
and this is just the way it is but we
didn't leave because of this and some
teachers and preachers and prominent
people within the church
in high up leadership
capacity
will say you dare not say
that the other
institutions and churches comprise
babylon
and that the deity that we serve is the
exact same deity as you find in some of
the other religious systems of the world
and the answer is
i am the lord your god that took you out
of egypt it's a very specific deity it's
not a general deity
and
this is this is a major problem
and we're going to have this problem
until the shaking takes
place
and
some of the harshest people
might become
poor
and some of the most timid people might
become nicodemus
and there will also be probably some
bright stars that will go out
correct
in fact we read that in the spirit of
prophecy
and many a star that is not now even
noticed will be noticed when it becomes
very dark
and these will shine
so don't lose courage within this church
the question is is this the final
message the final present truth bearing
organization in the world
yes can you call any level of leadership
or any level within the church babylon
no
is it possible that there are
babylonians in it yes no it's not only
possible it's an absolute fact that's it
all right are some of them real
babylonians
and others just influenced babylonians
possible yes
so we're living amidst the babylonians
that's it does that make me better than
them no no because i'm loud it's here
that's it
we have to all strive to get better we
all have a problem with character but i
can weep
and i can cry for all the evil that is
done
in israel
the lord has pronounced the curse upon
those who take from or add to the
scripture the great i am has decided
what shall constitute the rule of faith
and doctrine and he has designed that
the bible shall be a household book
the church that holds to the word of god
is
irreconcilably separated from rome
martin
does rome not peddle bibles
and we all do you ever see them
peddling
the receive text bibles no
they hate it they hate them
so which books do you want in your house
roman catholic approved bibles or bibles
that are
steeped in protestant theology because
they come from the manuscripts that god
gave to the reformers which ones would
you want
obviously if you want i want praise and
truth
protestants were once
thus apart from this great church of
apostasy
they have approached more nearly to her
and are still in the path of
reconciliation to the church of rome
do we have people in our own ranks that
think they must hobnobbit and bow down
to idols in roman catholic institutes
yes yes they will be popping up
more and more and more do i leave the
church because of them
no i think god is making it prominent
that they can be exposed ah
all right
and then this statement rome never
changes
so they can write articles as much as
they like
and they can belong to
divisions
they can be
union presidents
they can belong to the religious liberty
organization and write articles in favor
of these things and they can even give
gold medals to the pope do i leave the
church because leaders in this church
give gold medals to the pope no because
the worst darkness is sometimes an
opportunity to bring the light out
there's a statement in the spirit of
prophecy where it says that god permits
apostasy
to come into the church to wake up god's
people that's what it has to do wake up
and the more blatant it becomes
the more sure it will be that people
will wake up that's it
so rome never changes her principles
have not altered in the least she has
not lessened the breach between herself
and protestants they have done all the
advancing
the protestants that is
but what does this argue for the
protestantism of this day
it is the rejection of bible truth which
makes men approach to infidelity it is a
backsliding church
that lessens the distance between itself
and the papacy
so when you hear leaders
doing these things
they are backsliding
so what should we do
pray for them pray for them that's all
you can do do i leave the church because
of them no no because this church
doesn't have a top-down structure it has
a bottom-up structure so their apostasy
does not become my apostasy i don't have
a corporate apostasy because of certain
individuals within the church
so my
appeal would be
stay in the church
this is the remnant
then said jesus unto the 12 john 6 67
and they were confronted with present
truth
will you also go away
because when they heard prison truth
they turned and they left
and simon peter answered him lord to
whom shall we go thou hast the words of
eternal life
this is our attitude
what other church preaches the three
angels messages martin no what other
church has a universal distribution
that's an important thing because if you
splinter off from this remnant church
you won't have that voice
to reach everything everybody
you know there's a hymn that says and
though that wrong seems oft so
strong god is the ruler still
the seventh-day adventist church is not
babylon those who assert that the
seventh-day adventist churches
constitute babylon or any part of
babylon may better stay at home
let them stop and consider what is the
message to be proclaimed at this time
present truth
in place of working with divine agencies
to prepare a people to stand in the day
of the lord they have taken their stand
with him who is an accuser of the
brethren
who accuses them before god day and
night satanic agencies have been moved
from beneath
and they have inspired men to unite in a
confederacy of evil that they may
perplex harass and cause the people of
god great distress
the whole world is to be stirred with
enmity against seventh-day adventists
because they will not yield homage to
the papacy
by honoring sunday oh let me just stop
there martin
seventh-day adventists
do not yield homage to the papacy
so those that
yield homage to the papacy within our
ranks
can they be called seventh-day
adventists at this stage no no they're
not seventh-day adventists so that puts
that one to rest right
by honoring sunday the institution of
this anti-christian power it is the
purpose of satan to cause them to be
blotted from the earth in order that his
supremacy of the world may not be
disputed so within this church
there are seventh-day adventists yes
there is but one church in the world
who are at the present time standing in
the breach and making up the hedge
building up the old waste places and for
any man to call the attention of the
world and other churches to this church
denouncing her as babylon
is to do a work in harmony with him who
is the accuser of the brethren
the whole world is filled with hatred of
those who proclaim the binding claims of
the law of god
and the church who are loyal to jehovah
must engage in no ordinary conflict
those who have any realization of what
this warfare means will not turn their
weapons against the church militant
but with all their power will wrestle
with the people of god against the
confederacy of evil
so i cannot denounce the whole church as
evil but when i find evil must i lift up
my voice like a trumpet and tell the
house of jacob her sins yes that's what
the bible says that's it and you have
the authority in
the
body
to do something it's easy to take this
and to quote it and say you're not
allowed to attack the church at all
exactly what did jeremiah do did he send
them letters and tell them
how did they treat him
not very kindly not very kindly so we
have a duty
to tell the house of jacob her sins
but we have no right to call the whole
body
babylon
we have no right to do that
the christian world will learn what
romanism really is when it is too late
to escape the snare
so martin when i see these people
rubbing shoulders
it's like a mouse fiddling with a trap
i want to tell them come out get away
they run for your life
she is silently growing in power
doctrines are exerting their influence
in legislative halls
in the churches and in the hearts of men
do we see that happening yep
throughout the land she is piling up her
lofty and massive structures in the
secret recesses of which her former
persecutions will be repeated
she stealthily and unsuspectedly
strengthening her forces to further her
own ends when the time comes
for her to strike
all she desires is vantage ground
and this is soon to be given her in the
near future we will see and shall feel
what the purpose of the roman element is
whoever shall believe and obey the word
of god will thereby incur reproach and
persecution
is rome climbing on the medical
bandwagon as the right arm of her power
it
is the driving force
behind the soul and those mice that
sniffer that cheese
and think that it is a tasty morsel
will find that their nose might be
entrapped very soon
so the bottom line is martin
there are babylonians amongst us
they are babylonian
doctrines
being sold as
tasty
wine
but there is a remnant
that believes the three angels messages
that loves the present truth and that is
prepared to preach it at all costs
would you conquer that i want to be part
of that and i believe
we have to stand
therefore
let us stand
and if there are people in high places
that do not have the same philosophy
i shouldn't make that my problem that is
their problem
and god's problem and god's problem
and we are in this church because it
preaches present truth
and as long as there is breath
and as long as there are people that
believe the present truth this remains
the remnant amen
may god bless us and may god bless this
church and may god
wake up that desire
to share present truth with the world no
matter what the cost even if the cost is
from within we have more to fear from
within than from without
but that should not deter us
that does not make this church babylon
this is the final remnant with the final
message to the world let's pray
heavenly father
we are living in such troubles times and
the church is in such a turmoil
that it appears to topple and fall
but it will not
because it has a final message to bear
and behind that message stands the god
of the universe
and millions and billions of angels
open the eyes
that we may see
the hosts of god
behind this message
and help us to preach it with a power
that will shake this world
may it swell into a loud cry
and may many accept it in jesus name
amen
[Music]
you